we just got those PMI numbers out across
all of Europe they disappointed a little
bit not a whole lot in Germany in some
ways I'm looking more towards tomorrow
that's when we get factory orders for
the month of August that won't have
Volkswagen in there but it will give you
a sense of just where the manufacturing
industry is in Germany kind vehicle
production in Germany is four percent of
GDP that's the strict definition but if
we take a somewhat broader definition
the share in german gdp could be as high
as ten percent so obviously this could
have an impact on the macroeconomic
conditions a VW was one of the companies
that invested the most on China they had
forty percent unit sales in china and
twenty percent of revenues and for that
reason we've been cautious obviously we
couldn't forecast the idiosyncratic
event the you know the UH nemishe ins
but generally the story is shaky there's
been over investment in China by a lot
of companies they're still going to be
affected structurally by the slow down
so we remain cautious we were short VW
and we closed our short but we still
remain cautious
you have to give the public some
information you have to give them
information you have to explain why a
company like VW that's such an important
part of German industry could allow the
culture to go so bad because that the
root of corporate crisis is culture if
you train your employees to do the right
thing they will but it starts from the
top you really need a lot of effort to
regain their trust